est responsable du commerce pour une
ville en banlieue parisienne c'est une
ville très dynamique donc en soit je
cours partout
à la rencontre d'entrepreneurs bonjour
Ania salut
public et je suis toujours soit dans les
commerces en entreprise ou en contact
avec les gens d'âge particulièrement
difficile pour la trentenaire
lorsqu'elle a ses règles
une française sur 10 Tanina souffre
d'endométriose j'ai une endommette
sévère donc de stade 4 sur 4
donc oui c'est quelque chose je ne peux
pas me lever les règles douloureuses de
Tanina ont longtemps eu un impact sur sa
vie professionnelle j'ai toujours adapté
et faire en sorte d'éviter les
déplacements d'éviter les choses comme
ça tant que vous pouvez parce que sinon
pour pouvoir venir sinon je devais
prendre beaucoup de médicaments ou
parfois ne pas venir de tout
n'a plus besoin de redouter cette
pénible semaine et là maintenant droit à
un congé menstruel deux jours par mois
sans note du médecin j'ai envie de vous
dire enfin d'être entendu en fin de dire
qu'on peut rester qu'on peut rester à la
maison ce congé lui a été accordé par
son employeur la mairie de Saint-Ouen
pour le maire socialiste il s'agissait
d'une évidence on a été surpris en
apprenant que nous étions la première
ville sur quelques 800 femmes à l'emploi
de la mairie une cinquantaine ont déjà
demandé un congé menstruel un couple
mère est prêt à assumer même en cas
d'abus si on arrive à voir entre 5 et
10% de de dérive c'est pas grave en
Europe l'idée du congé menstruel
commence à faire son chemin l'Espagne
l'a instauré en février et en France les
supermarchés Carrefour l'offriront
bientôt à certaines de leurs 50000
salariés c'est un petit pas qui va dans
la bonne direction cette sénatrice veut
aller plus loin avec un congé menstruel
national si le cadre légal existe mais
ça veut dire que en effet ça deviendra
quelque chose comme le congé maternité
aujourd'hui un employeur n'a pas le
choix de dire bah non moi ça ne
m'arrange pas il y a pas de congé
maternité par exemple sa proposition de
loi à prévoirait deux jours de congés
payés par mois sur présentation d'un
certificat médical
cette avocate est militante féministe le
congé menstruel est une fausse bonne
idée qui risque de mener à plus de
discrimination comme le congé menstruel
peut se poser chaque mois effectivement
les employeurs peuvent se dire que ça
sera quelques jours d'absence qu'un
homme ne posera pas et donc discriminer
les femmes à l'embauche ou dans leur
promotion l'évolution de carrière pour
féminin la question de la discrimination
ne se pose pas quelqu'un ne veut pas
vous recruter vous recrutera pas quoi
qu'il arrive là jeune femme ne s'imagine
pas revenir à sa vie d'avant le conjugue
menstruel lorsque le simple fait d'aller
au travail pouvait devenir un défi
insurmontable
[Musique]